[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you tapped into the group chat presented
by fanduel live in the bleach report app
my name is cabbie richards
our betting expert is in the middle she
builds her empire brick by brick
differently than kelly ubre's bricks
that is
and on the end no he he wins a lot on
wednesdays but needs some more wins
today on a thursday that is greg ivory
i have a problem with the way that i
actually why why did you have to do that
bro why did
shout out to kelly ubra you know he's a
warrior
he's a warrior lawyer he's in some brick
houses right those are bad vibes cabbie
don't get out of it the truth about your
team greg
if you've been with us in the chat this
season you know we've been hammering our
new custom
quick hitter bet the three by two and so
far
four and oh baby last week um
if you're with us we asked you if
there'd be two three pointers made in
the first three minutes
of milwaukee versus miami we decided to
ride with you the audience
and we cashed charles barkley
unfortunately
did not and here's what happened will
there be two threes made in the first
three minutes of the game first three
minutes
that's a tough one though that's the
reason because you don't come out
jacking up three
oh sometimes you do i will go i'm gonna
go under
oh so you're gonna you say no i'm
changing your mind
dragons up bringing the ball up 35
seconds left
for the three by two [ __ ] [ __ ]
hit mikey broken
[Music]
that was tremendous i'm so much fomo the
joy the pure
joy ah that warms my heart baby
very vibey right there shout out to
duncan robinson shouts out to mikey he
brought the vibes
hey before before the show i was bro i
tried so hard callie
kelly and kathy i tried so hard to get
our producer max
to insert the video of me and
uh my guy mikey locks talking about a
beautiful
beautiful sunset right before the shot
he didn't he didn't add it he didn't add
it but
but what i need is everybody in the
comments give me those vibes because
we're riding the 3x2 today
i need the sunset emoji in the comments
right now
sunset emoji in the comments i'm giving
away hoodies actually i'm gonna give
away some hoodies right now why not
the silver star don't cut me off either
cabbie
here we go here we ate deep geek is in
the in the comments this is a new show
deep geek you're walking away with the
hoodie brother
he uh he's in the comments and he's
saying uh
he's saying that it's gonna be under two
he doesn't think that it's gonna happen
d geek you're walking away with a hoodie
i got brian
cain bridge he's saying that uh
he's saying that joe harris will cash it
he's saying that joe harris will catch
it so they're back and forth in the
comments kevin they are back and forth
in the comments
okay so last week we wrote with yes that
there will be a three by
two and we listen to our audience
actually just today
we put us a poll out on social excuse me
on twitter
will there be two three pointers made in
the first three minutes
of tonight's game the philadelphia 76ers
versus the brooklyn nets let us see the
results of the poll right now
we are leaning 75 yes we are
all optimistic that there's gonna be two
three-pointers made in the first three
minutes of the game
because of guys like joe harris or
tobias harris
uh one note it was just announced that
kyrie irving will not be playing in
tonight's game due to personal reasons
that was announced just a few minutes
ago so the nets will be out
will be without their superstar point
guard in tonight's game
so where are we at do we believe that
there were
even without kyrie that there will be
two three-pointers made in the first
three minutes of the game kel's i'm
going to start with you
gabby you mentioned we're 4-0 and look i
know it's a small sample size and we
talk about math all the time but i'm
going to keep it simple i'm not
going to fade us here we're on a hot
streak we're going to keep it rolling
we're going yes plus 110.
okay i'm rocking with the audience too
cows that's a that's a yes for me
and because seth curry was lights out
last night
um also tobias harris and danny green
like we just need
one of those dudes and joe harris or
maybe charis lavert to hit a
three-pointer so i'm leaning yes to
along with the audience g-money how
about yourself and what are the comments
are saying
about the three by two even with the
news
that kyrie is not playing tonight abby
i'm in the comments
and uh they're they're you they're
pretty straightforward with it they're
pretty straightforward
my guy down to earth said easy two
threes he is rocking with it uh bryce is
back in the comments
saying easy easy easy big mike 13.
yes sir over
shirt please sunset
guess what big mike you're walking away
with a hoodie not a shirt you're walking
away with a hoodie
cabbie it is a parent it is a parent the
comment is saying yes
and the poll said yes 75 percent
i guess i guess i'm a rock with the yes
i guess
so check out br betting's social
channels for the link to the 3x2 on
fanduel that is very important
and as always if it hits like it has
been all season
send us your videos because we want to
see that celebration all right
so um these people have been uh
cooking recently steph curry had 62 brad
beal had 60
and bead had 38.
let's go right to the mvp conversation
because
this is always the most titillating luca
doncic is at the top
plus 410 you have the reigning two-time
mvp yana santa tecumpo
plus 550 kds at plus 700 your dude after
a monster 62 point game
g-money steph curry is climbing plus
9.50
where are you leaning on abby and the
heavy wait wait wait wait time i i don't
mean to cut you off brother
but who's the favorite luca doncic
the 21 22 year old phenom bro what do
you mean
lucas the favorite that's of course
that's cap we got giannis k.d steph
luca just had a triple double like two
games ago what are you talking about
he's again he's going to be the face of
the nba
in like t-minus two or three years
that's cap
i need the comments the comments the
comments tell me is it cap that luca is
the favorite
i need no cap is the red x with the blue
cap i need
cap with just the blue cap i need cap in
the comments cap or no cap in the
comments
should luca be favorite so who could be
favorite you know that
everybody's gonna rock with luca vegas
is rocking with luca
i don't know kelly are you on the same
tip luca for mvp
look i i do think luca especially in his
performance
last year in the bubble i do think that
he is the front runner for a reason
also you have to remember you gotta move
some of the voters here this isn't just
all based on performance i think a lot
of people like
luca and even though he is young he does
have some good leadership skills
do i think there's any value on betting
on luca no i do not
all right so you know what that's one
thing that kelly has
been very uh staunch about is teaching
us about
value so if i look at the board and we
again see the the front runners for mvp
i like kevin durant at plus 700 and if
i'm really gonna listen to kelly stewart
which i
i generally lean on i like that jason
tatum at
plus where is he he's not even on the
board
2700 the last time i checked on fanduel
i love that young man from boston and
he's carrying the celtics right now
him and jaylen brown so that's where i'm
leaning g-money
i can't believe we have we have lucas
slander on the show
but if you're not leaning towards luka
doncic where are you leaning in the nba
they're all over you in the comments
look at the handy-dandy ipad right here
they're over you they're saying cabbies
cabbie it's cap just stop my guy big
mike said cabbie it's cap just stop
but hold on hold on la to indy dad 724
he said no cap he did say no cap la
uh tandy you're walking away with hoodie
cabbie i'm back into the comments
luca god let's go luca all the way
mvp mvp mvp handy dandy ipad they're
back and forth i'm telling you i see
cap more than i see no cap i promise you
cabbie
spencer's spencer's cap
they're they're they're saying cap
cabbie they're okay so what do you say
who's your mvp vote if you're if you're
saying that the commenters are rife with
cap
okay let me let me break this down to
you let me break this down to you
my heart my heart is telling me step
three
in order for the warriors to have a
successful season steph curry
needs to ball i mean kelly why are you
doing all that he was just
he just was player of the week last
there is a little bit of this going on
right here
deep down inside greg
he was just player of the week on a
regular basis this year in order to be
mvp i'm
the thing is you're absolutely right
that's why my
mind is telling me damien
lillard sitting at sitting at uh
he's up there he's up there he's at the
pressure 2600.
i don't know he put a hundred grand on
the blazers to come out of the west
though
hey if charles picked it or not
i'm riding with my guy from oakland bay
area legend
dame lillard sitting at plus 2600 kelly
you talk value
look at this value down here i love this
i love this a lot like i'm with you
listen you're right i i've taught you
well here you picked somebody that was
above ten to one odds unlike
cabbie over here taking the easy ones
look i'm not gonna vet
mvp this is not i'm not gonna take my
hard-earned cash
and bet on something that's six months
down the road when we can see
catastrophic things happen to that vet
in the name of
injury etc so don't bring the bad vibes
look i don't want to tire my money for
that long if you're going to make me
choose i'm going to take nicola jokic
why because it correlates
with my denver nuggets bet to win
the west i think that if denver is gonna
get
into the western conference finals
they're gonna need a lot of help from
the joker
and the joker is currently leading the
nba in assists which is just
mind-boggling but that guy is so
talented he's such a generational
player very exciting even though he
moves
at a glacial he moves as fast as greg
and i do on the basketball court
uh no disrespect to nicola jokic so um
let's move on to our the most ridiculous
part of the show
this is when greg ivory builds a single
game parlay
in week one he was one for five in week
two
there was marginal improvement he was
two for five
so so what ridiculousness have you
brought for us
for tonight's single game parlay dallas
versus denver g-money the parley is
yours
cabbie kelly
we finally reached the best part of the
show it is this is the most
ridiculous part of the show it is time
it is take a look at last week
this is a no-hate zone i'm just spitting
facts look hold on
let's let's see last week's ticket let's
take a look
no hate zone in the comments needs you
guys no hate zone in the comments
bro no hates that ticket no hate zone
i need more no hate zone in the comments
cabbie is throwing a lot of hate my way
when we are graduating bifocals we are
gradually
improving that's what it's about it's
about growth here
you have a 500 bet with kelly bro you
need to hit one of these
i'm gonna hit i'm gonna hit cabbie do
not worry
we will hit let's get started let's get
into it let's get
right into it with the first leg cabbie
kelly the first leg we're rocking with
gary
harris under kelly do you hear that
under two and a half rebounds
what do you guys have to say you're
gonna be sitting tight all night bro
he's a guard he can get any one of those
wild rebounds off the rim
tabby i think we're all right i think
gary harris reap
i think we're all right moving
on moving on jamal murray
over 21 and a half points we see him
having a big day
shout out to my guy luke locks he is on
the power ranking list and he's from
where you from kev he's from toronto
shout out to my guy shout out to my guy
luke locks
moving on tim hardaway
jr under kelly this is for you
under three and a half three pointers
made
uh he had a big game last week cabbie
eight
last game but you know he's streaky you
know he's streaky yeah you know he's
streaky
we're back we're betting on him to uh be
himself
he's be cold today you're streaky he was
hot last game we might need a
cold streak coming on so we're betting
against tim hardaway being himself here
we go we're moving on
uh jamal murray over
two and a half made threes
rocking with jamal murray over two and a
half may threes do see him having a big
game too cabbie that's your boy
it is that's your best my dude it's
gonna be tight as well it's gonna be a
tight one
i was doing this thinking of you i was
you know i was like man cavi might
actually agree with me this time he
might actually agree with me this time
hold on greg time out you have four legs
of the parley and
i don't see a luca or nicole jokic
player prop what are you doing bro
yo you see what this is
the finale okay you're saving it for the
finale okay here we go
here we go i never said that i said you
see how we rocking but you know what you
know what
every time we come in this segment it's
always two against one
it's always cabbie kelly giving me grief
it's it's always two against one it's
all you guys betting against me
picked up by the big brother
you guys are betting against me you guys
are are
are are just degrading my parlay
so i had to make a phone call i had to
tap in with one of my uh
who wants to be a millionaire you're
gonna phone a friend
hey kelly hey sometimes you got to do
what you got to do
you got to do what you got to do i have
to make a phone call i had to tap in
with one of my uh
one of my lieutenants on the winners
only squad
my guy brasco
hey my guy brasco got my back like no
other kelly cabby i finally got somebody
on my side so i'm feeling
good i'm feeling good now brasco brasco
brasco the floor is yours bro welcome to
the show
bro thank you take this parlay to the
next level
take it to the next level with the last
pick go ahead lock it up let's get the
fifth leg
let's relay that baton home let's go
with the over
in the fourth quarter i see this being a
close game
gonna be a shootout to the end maybe you
know murray
uh luca trading buckets at the end foul
situation
clutch threes let's go over 54 and a
half points
in the fourth quarter in a close one
that's going to lock it up
my guy wow like who
who even builds a parlay like that the
fourth
quarter over i've never even heard of
such a thing brazil
have you ever have you ever heard of
something like that
being a leg of a parliament i've never
heard of any of this until fanduel
put this together same game parlay this
is all so
foreign to me you have no idea but uh i
actually don't hate brasco's best uh
fourth quarter prophet i really don't
all of greg's nonsense is
for another day but that's a i like that
thing i think he's right i think it is
gonna be a very close game down to the
stretch
we will just go at the end brasco don't
don't don't fall into it she's just
trying to trap it's my game thing
it's a mind game we got the kobe
mentality we're not listening to it
we're not listening to it
we got the kobe mentality uh
winning this morning roscoe before you
get out of here i gotta get an imitation
of the great ali
what are you rocking with one more time
tell them no if ali
ali number one of the power rankings if
he gives you a soccer bet
we're going greg over two and a half
goal
saudi arabia over over over over
let's go winners only please
yes sir yes sir thank you brasco thank
you we're rocking with the over
over over in the fourth quarter brasco
appreciate you brody
i appreciate you for tapping in man
appreciate you for tapping in
i'ma tap in later man i'm gonna tap in
later we gotta talk some of those games
going to the graphic now
we are going to the graphic as you guys
can see uh
gary harris under two and a half
rebounds jamal murray
uh over 21 and a half points tim
hardaway jr
uh they just took away my graphic for me
but it's okay because i got it right
here
more importantly fifteen to one what are
you doing here
come on buddy we talked about this you
gotta be like 25 to one
or better none of this like minus 140s
minus one sixties partly together come
on
so now you're trying to change rules
midway through the season like i'm gonna
catch my 500
back i'm just saying this is weeks off
okay
okay okay as as long as we we got an
understanding that when this one hits
i still get my money so uh that's all
that matters
that's that's that's all that matters
well good luck to you g money
and a legendary uh appearance from
brasco bets and a legendary impression
of a legend so thank you for that
listen thank you very much for tapping
into the group chat presented by fanduel
remember what you learned today the nba
is a marathon
not a sprint in lucca we trust and the
3x2 is the easiest
money on the board alongside kelly
stewart and greg ivory i'm cabby
richards we are leaving the group chat
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you